of all of them are zolensky
when President Mr President greeting so
a short introductory word
okay well today I've had a lot of
introductory words in fact
but I'll start with the word of thanks
thanks to the representatives of media
to journalists
and I think that what you've done over
this year is very important
to I'd like to express words of
gratitude to this invincible journalists
really you've done a lot for the
strengths of our Nations
the Armed Forces of Ukraine was fighting
the whole people the citizens of Ukraine
was fighting and you did your own role
um so
the same goes to the representatives of
our foreign Partners so and that ma'am
confident
that you know you fully recognize what
you've done for the victory all this
feeling will come so big words of
gratitude to you for speaking about
Ukraine for the fact that the whole
world is not forgetting about Ukraine
this allows us to remain strong
to remain invincible and Unbreakable
so
this already a year of invincibility so
big thanks to you
big words of gratitude to your
colleagues
that are unfortunately no longer with us
foreign
because they've died in Ukraine we have
people like that
representatives of your
very important profession so I guess it
would be fair
to recognize all those people with a
minute of Silence a minute of Silence to
those that we all remember
it's important to us I think it's
important to everyone now I think with
all
we can we can start
we can start talking yes don't forget to
raise your tablets and introduce
yourselves so Christian please CNN
okay Mr President thank you for taking
this question
can we get him down
Mr President I'm interested in the
timeline today on the anniversary you
spoke to your own forces and you called
for victory within this year
you have heard the Western friends your
partners talk about as long as it takes
you know that the Russian leader
believes that time is on his side why do
you think that it's possible by the end
of the year and how do you assess the
meaning of as long as it takes
from your Ukrainian perspective
thank you for this question
I really want and I think that every
single partner everyone
will remain strong
will remain just as a as a fist if all
of our partners are united for the sake
of our Victory because that's a victory
of values if all of them will remain
committed to their words to their time
frames
that's not going to be just talking but
we've already shown ourselves as strong
partners and there's evidence to that so
should all of us do this important
homework
if we'll fulfill our tasks then we'll
definitely have this Victory I'm
confident that we'll have this Victory
and I hope this will happen this year we
have everything to have it this year we
have friends we have debunk diplomacy we
have you we have combined everything
against this wave of Invaders I think
not a single country in the world can
withstand on its own uh something
against this war
um for I think on the United States
would be capable to to do that but
fortunately they don't have labels like
that there's just a couple of uh
countries like that in the world and
Ukraine is facing this war not alone we
have friends we make sure this
aggression this war would not continue
any anywhere else we clearly understand
what the Putin wants what Kremlin wants
we understand what the military
political leadership want so it's it's
important for everyone to focus to stay
working in in their own places and
that's it and then we'll have Victory
because
the truth the righteous is on our side
and the children that we love and it's
so horrible when we are losing them in
the battlefield around the battlefield
but then but they Russians they they
have countless of uh victims and
casualties that's their choice now ictv
Oksana
president good afternoon Mr President
first thank you for your example of
resilience invincibility and believe we
all believe in the victory but now a lot
of international experts are are telling
that we have a war of exhaustion and not
a single party would have a resources to
have an
um
Victory clear Victory and then there
will be a negotiation so how do these
negotiations look like what's the
ultimate victory for Ukraine looks like
I'm not thinking theoretically about how
those negotiations could take legs we
make very specific stamps Ukraine has
initiated the peace formula at G20
although
we would really like to have it g90 and
not G20 in the world so we've uh briefed
everyone on the peace formula how we see
that and then there's the outcome of
what Russia has done here and how it has
an impact not only on our security
because there are different crises
caused by Russia's aggressive steps as
you know the occupation of the nuclear
power plant in zapore Asia and then the
blocking of the sea and all the chains
of Supply
um as part of the full security you know
all of those aspects
so what else can I tell you we've
offered the steps and today we can see
some interests in fulfilling this peace
formula and supporting that and I'd like
to express words of gratitude to the
country because uh yesterday in fact
it's today night
41 countries has supported our peace
initiative at the general assembly so
the next step would be to engage as much
as possible States
for the first um The Summit I want
really this Summit to be as much
fruitful as possible so that we would
have this Summit conducted in a place in
a country that would be able to host as
much countries of the world as possible
and working with our partners with the
team
in order to
make sure that
not only the Strategic partners that are
supporting us from the first days to be
there at the peace formula Summit
and we're working hard to have
representatives from different
continents we're working hard to have uh
Latin America represented at this uh
Global peaceful formula Summit and so
that there would be representatives of
the African continent so they would be
engaged in this Summit as well we're
also like Frankly Speaking I would like
to have India I would like to have China
participating that's that's true our
task is to engage as much as possible to
show the whole world that here's the
respect to the territorial Integrity the
U.N Charter to uh the uh anyone's right
to leave and the more countries will
Engage The more support we will have and
we'll div we have developed a peace
formula in a way which is very
Democratic so it's a very
um clear step so in order to reduce the
risks among the country supporting us I
mean any country can support like a
single point of this peace formula they
could support a nuclear safety the
environmental safety and you know how
many minds
are there around the territory of
Ukraine that's why there is a lot of
steps that we've offered and there is
also kind of a a staff that means the
the bringing of Peace because we need
the security guarantees and this is
something we need like a Security
package for Ukraine for ukrainians and
already we can see that this is the war
that has a very significant impact so a
security guarantees for the whole Europe
so where there is this fulfillment and
then there is this respect to the
international law and to the Ordinary
People to the people of Ukraine so if
that would be uh fulfilled then we'll
get
a diplomatic kind of a the end of this
war but until that moment we need to
fulfill all these points of respect
sorry Mr President you were mentioning
the resolution in the United Nations the
more than 140 countries that voted
demanding that Russia forces leave
Ukraine immediately and without
conditions what do you say to the
countries the minority that didn't
support uh that resolution that voted
with Russia against it or that
decided to ignore it
um
in order to understand the war the
consequences and the losses as the
result of the workers you're not only
losing the territory but you're losing
people leaving people
and uh if you're not at War if you
haven't ever lost anyone then it's hard
for you to understand what's happening
what what sort of pain is that for for
everyone around you and it's hard to to
spread this information and this is why
we are working every day in order
anyone to understand the consequences of
the war not through having this war
because it's painful it's a weak
position because you're somewhere there
and you're saying that we're not sure
that in this way but in how in what way
should you definitely have a war with
slaughtering with rapes should you have
it should you need to have it in every
house the war so that the people would
finally understand the consequences of
this bloody war
and then this big
leadership of this Russian Federation
then there is this journalism to have
this information been spread it's hard
to get this information to those uh
countries uh that are vote against it
but still we've we are working there's
141 countries who voted in favor of that
there is this supportive territorial
integrity and sovereignty so there's the
answer how these countries are what sort
of attitude do they have a so there's an
answer in this support yes they have the
withdraw from your Sovereign territory
now how do we work with other countries
we do work and I believe that Ukraine
really needs to make steps forward
like towards the African countries I
think we've worked
not at a sufficient level we didn't pay
sufficient attention to the African
countries that is why we have a special
program initiated by Ukraine we are
increasing the number of embassies in
the region and then look at the grain
from Ukraine initiative and other
initiatives
food security so this is what you need
to do at Daily investments in fees I
think we wasted that time for many years
since the beginning of our independence
and that is why currently we are
fighting for our independence
and that's not a coincidence we didn't
have a strong fist of Partners before
the war end that's right but now we have
it but we're still lacking a number of
individuals at this fist over uh come
and support so and I'm talking about the
African continent the Latin America it's
also very important and I would really
like to have a conference and a meeting
or rather a summed with the Latin
American countries and Ukraine and it's
very difficult for me to leave outside
of Ukraine but I would go I would go to
this meeting to tell their media to tell
their society like I'm ready to to step
forward our diploments are are making
the step forwards we're ready to work
round o'clock if we'll get more hours in
the daytime we will do that so this is
how you would need to work 30 years
unfortunately it was the war that made
us work
so effectively but nobody would have
expected something like that out of
neighboring country or Russia that you
would have something like that from
Russia there's this just willingness to
destroy us completely utterly
and that's why it's not a Corruption of
mistakes
uh like to say that I don't have any
questions to anyone I don't want to deal
with that part of the past and I'm
looking at the future we need the total
support of the world of the war and we
will be victorious we're working on that
and that dialogue is absolutely fair
this is a dialect with many countries
we've worked on the unification of the
European countries and that's not only
the human Nations but other countries
the countries with different status with
neutral status and we've worked in order
to change this neutrality T into the
non-neutral status to warn this is also
very important we worked on this every
day
a lot but you have worked on that and
the armed forces have worked on that
because the victory is on the
battlefield that gives confidence nobody
likes losers however hard it might sound
but that's the truth everyone wants to
be Victorious and everyone has to work
like inside the country and outside the
country that the only way the only way
to Victory thank you so much thank you
dear colleagues ayalta European
strategist Sir Jeffrey nice do you have
a question maybe a first row
thank you very much
um Mr President
those fighting for your country led by
you and you
have put you on moral Peaks
not just High Ground from which you can
make requests or demands
of the Western World whose methods of
accountability for war crimes are
unsatisfactory
incomplete and very very slow
will you for yourselves
and also for us
push for reform of those systems or
additions to them
that will ensure there can be because
this is in your country's interests the
earliest possible
and conclusive determination of where
moral right in this war is
and where moral wrong is
and supplementary to that Mr President
will you consider
to the extent possible
ensuring that accountability mechanisms
for war crimes
are dealt with
by ukrainians
in Ukraine
and in the Ukrainian language
remembering
the country is supporting you
if they found themselves in your
terrible and unhappy situation
would demand nothing less
for themselves
thank you
thank you for your question
it's a quite complicated one but
actually it had all the answers in it it
is very profound
and I know there are a lot of risks
as far as the peace formula is concerned
regarding the institutions uh first let
me speak about the tribunal everything
starts with the political Unity the
United Nations platform might not
necessarily be the universal one but
there's nothing else that would have
more countries that could be politically
United as of now unfortunately I don't
think there's anything else and we can
support the setting up of the tribunal
uh to hold Russian Federation
accountable for war crimes and we're
also working on the mechanism to
compensate all the damage caused by
Russia on the territory of our country
to our country and to our people this is
a major effort we're working on it the
diplomats
um Office of the President Mr Austin Mr
Your Mark prosecutor General the office
of the prosecutor General everybody is
working hard every day to make sure it
is up and running this is a very
sophisticated mechanism
and actually I have to say that
other countries they are cautious they
are afraid of setting up tribunals you
might understand why that it is it's a
matter of responsibility but before you
go and establish something in your
country you need the political will and
unity unification and un has been very
useful in that respect because
uh any government country or leader can
receive support to that process and
we're working on that as well we are
convinced that the resolutions will be
supported and voted for we're working
with certain countries that we see as uh
crucial for the matters of tribunal we
see them as Leaders this is actually the
Netherlands we're working with Mark
drute we are working with Mr Richard
sunak from the UK with other countries
as well we are thinking about the
compensation mechanism there has already
been a few steps already in our Baltic
friends uh a very helpful and Baltic
Trio and Paula and they have been
supportive along the way they have
supported us with everything we ask for
uh why is it so hard
because
well to address the first part of your
question these institutions that you
refer to were set up a long time ago
they haven't been through
this
type of immense aggression and this
bureaucratic system does not give a
clear answer to the question of when uh
the justice will be served when fairness
will happen and for those who lost their
homes
the economy everything they want Justice
now and it makes sense that they won't
Justice and fairness we have specific
examples we were working on the matter
of prisoners of war and Andrei in
particular and
other colleague eggs they were taking a
great care to check the condition of the
prisoners of War as you've heard they've
been tortures and now the the Red Cross
it's an international institution they
didn't manage to the prisoners of War to
check their condition uh are they
hard-working
insisting no we were insistent in
working hard we were doing our best
paying immense effort to get our men and
women out but to this day we do not have
access to the prisoners of War
and this year the year is the year of
the full-scale war but we have to
remember that the War Began in 2014. and
we know that there are 125 creamy and
tatars that are political prisoners what
is happening to them now
um I remember early into my presidential
term we were returning people back to
Ukraine samples organizations
foreign
and you know I am tired to hear one
answer from many institutions they keep
saying we don't have the authority to do
it
um
so
no Universal mandate etc etc but
nonetheless uh the U.N headed by Antonio
guterres
and well in us we became more proactive
um came to Ukraine and we helped
organize the corridor to transport grain
with help of turkey so
persistent being persistent and being
committed to change institutions is what
helps actually this war
helps highlight weaknesses weaknesses in
your Union institutions in the EU on the
continent in general and international
institutions as well and
um how do we change them a different
security infrastructure will emerge
after the Victor in the war somebody
from Ukrainian media lb UA
thank you good afternoon Mr President
you mentioned China and it's a
I refuse not to very pre-ukrainian China
came up with its peace plan uh this week
however we're seeing some
actions by China not very pre Ukrainian
and we also heard some allegations that
China might be supporting weapons to
Russia so what do you think about
China's position well I don't think that
was China's peace plan it was not a
declaration or resolution I think that
China spoke its mind
about the matter and I actually said it
once before
China started talking about Ukraine and
I think this is a good thing
but
it actually
um it begs a question
um
what will these words be followed with
because the steps that are to be taken
this is what's important and what these
steps are going to lead to for us
because he's talking about uh China is
talking about us
territorial integrity
well I think
what they are saying looks like respect
for territorial Integrity doesn't
mention the country but it's our
territorial Integrity that has been
breached uh nuclear security was
mentioned as well I think this is in
line with the interests Global interest
and Ukrainian interest they're
some things that may sense to me there
are things that I disagree with the
entire world I think disagrees with but
nonetheless this is at least something
and I think that uh
we uh would be safe to assume that if
there are ideas that are aligned with
the idea of respect for international
law territorial integrity and some
security considerations
we need to put that to good use we need
to work on that with China why not
foreign
our task is
to get everyone together to isolate
that somebody next question from
Missouri by John
uh
good evening Dear Mr President I'm a
journalist from Azerbaijan um
of what is the support to Ukraine from
the post-soviet countries from
Azerbaijan in particular
what specific steps do you anticipate
and what specific steps are you planning
to take in internal and external uh
policy uh Mr President my son asked to
take a selfie with you would that be
okay we'll start with what your son has
asked and then we'll discuss the
question that you posed
dear colleagues but this is a bad
example please please don't be doing
that
so your question was um
about my assessment of azerbaijan's
support
good time well actually the answer is
and the question
if and as a virgin journalist is asking
a question in Ukrainian that means he
has made a choice between Russia and
Ukraine thank you for your support thank
you regarding president Olive we are in
touch with him
um
we communicate with him we are grateful
to for his support that he's extended to
Ukraine and he respects uh our
sovereignty I think that's priority
number one he has respect for the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine he
um
thinks that Crimea is Ukraine thank you
let's talk to this part of the room on
PR National Public Radio
thank you
can you hear me okay hi hi so General
Millie says that you can't achieve your
goal of kicking all the Russians out of
Ukraine
um I wanted to see if you think he's
right and what that tells you about
continued U.S support and why
thank you for this question
first of all I know General milley
personally we had a meeting
and I haven't heard that from him
I respect the opinions and views of the
military especially the partners that
have been supporting us that have been
leaders in our supportive General melee
uh really thinks that I think I would
have heard that before
um
secondly
support is everything
so if General Millie
um
[Music]
I think the most important was the visit
of the President Biden
um there's weapons uh other things and
it's up to the president and Congress
but first of all it's support of the
public and I saw that American people
they support us uh during my visit to
Washington DC I saw people with
Ukrainian Flags in the streets so I know
that the U.S support is very very
important
and support is weapons humanitarian
assistance etc etc that's one thing and
there's another thing believing in our
Victory and this is what uh President
Biden's visit was about and President
Biden came to us in general really
hasn't been here yet Sky News Deborah
please
and thank you very much Deborah Haynes
from Sky News do you believe that
Ukraine can achieve Victory on the
battlefield or do you believe that
ultimately you're going to have to
negotiate maybe even compromise maybe
even talk to Vladimir Putin and if I may
ask a second question please
um
20 around 20 of NATO's member states
have increased their defense spending or
made pledges to increase their defense
spending following the full-scale
invasion of Ukraine last year
would you like to see all 30 member
states increase their defense spending
given the need to continue to support
Ukraine and that does include the UK
which has yet to do that thank you
thank you for your question
if I forget something please make sure
to remind me
this um this important thing 20
countries is a lot but there are so many
countries around the world who started
to
uh increase their defense budget so this
is uh a complicated matter and requires
a complicated answer there was a
previous question how do you reform
institutional security globally and you
are talking about increase in defense
budgets that's the answer the war in
Ukraine
gave rise to the resetting uh everybody
understood that the systems are not
perfect that we need something more
powerful and I'm not talking about
ammunition uh there's a lot spent
um on cyber security information
Independence Etc
Etc
uavs
I.T cutting-edge Technologies
everybody's clear that
there's no cookie cutter approach
um probably other expenses are increased
as well but bottom line is that what
we're seeing now is the security system
being reformed and I think this is the
right step to take and
um
Everybody saw what we could expect from
the Russian Federation
and this brings us to the idea of
compromise and negotiations
we all saw that nobody ran to buy
flowers
instead everybody went to buy weapons
nobody wants to develop business with uh
Russian Federation more and more
sanctions appear sometimes sanctions
hurt but
um everybody is clear now that they're
making you dependent on Russian gas and
if you are that dependent then you're
gonna get cold eventually
because at some point they might start
thinking that they want to uh to have
their people in your country they want a
part of your territory
and then people realize that we need
Independence not just on paper we need
real Independence to defend our people
because this is what that one person has
done with independent Ukraine who was a
neighbor and
um even sort of say a friend yesterday
so this brings me back to the first part
of your question after everybody saw
there that they killed people that they
torture people and they're not even
trying to hide their attacks
they're talking about
nuclear matters
they
decided to take Iranian drones and kill
civilians
and those civilians were did not have
guns in their hands they had their
children in their hands
and seeing this picture of the world do
you think we ukrainians could sit at
this
to negotiate with all of this I don't
know how to call that we call this uh
phenomena rashism I I don't have a
better word to put it so that's that's
the answer
we
need to start from scratch we need to go
back to what was violated
our right to live on our land needs to
be respected leave our territory
withdraw stop shelling uh us stop
killing civilians stop destroying our
infrastructure energy sector potable
water stop
air strikes on the city stop killing
dogs cats animals stop burning the
forest
so you go ahead and stop doing all of
that and only after that we'll tell you
what format will be used to
diplomatically uh put an end to it
okay now the Ukrainian Pravda please
from this part of the audience
I'd like to go back to the major topic
of this press conference that's the year
of the war it's time for some
intermediate conclusions and my question
is sort of personal it's composed of
three components first can you recall
your personality the most horrible day
and the horrible night of the full scale
War
secondly we're all humans we can all
make mistakes now what's your biggest
mistake over the period of the uh
full-scale War
over the spirit of the foreskin
who sort of disappointed you thank you
okay I'd like to start with the the the
one who disappointed me oh sorry because
so uh who disappointed all those who
left on the 24th of February all those
who left Kiev all those who were living
cities and towns all those who were
supposed to fight for the country who
had to take care of the security of this
country so all these people have
disappointed me now my largest mistake
I don't know I think there was some of
them
I'm working
um from early morning to late night I'm
a living person
and um no matter how someone might think
of that so I I do I make choices so I am
convinced that I'm making mistakes from
time to time what's important is that
for me not to have any fatal mistakes
because I'm a guarantor of the
Constitution I'm the guarantor of the
National Security so what's important is
that I won't make any fatal mistakes now
with God helps I've uh
haven't made any any any
mistakes like that now what would the
horrible day or the horrible night the
most horrible night
hmm
over this year
I think butcher
what I've saw
it
the moment we've deoccupied butcher
it was it was horrible uh
thank you